hey everybody and welcome to an insane
wild ride with stevo we've got aaron
carter and i gotta say he's out of his
mind this is every bit as wild as all
the other interviews you've seen him do
and maybe even crazier plus we get
unbelievable scoops like i think this
one's gonna have a lot of news articles
but i tell you this from the road on my
bucket list tour sitting in front of
what i believe is a 1.7 million dollar
tour bus
we are living in absolute luxury right
now but i gotta say
i'm going without some things that i do
not like to go without namely i don't
have any liquid death in the fridge and
that is a problem because i love liquid
death what is it it's sparkling and
still water from the alps that comes in
infinitely recyclable 16 ounce tall boy
cans which are made to look like beers
this company has the best sense of humor
out of any company ever you got to
follow them on instagram just to see the
crazy things they post
and they donate 10 of their profits to
ridding the world of plastic man they're
out here to save the world and they're
out here to make you a healthier person
and they're just awesome dude i love
liquid death and it bothers me i don't
have one in my hand right now but you
can have them in your hand if you go to
liquiddeth.com
stevo you know what that's gonna get you
free shipping on any order of
uh water or merch
and you know how crazy it is that
they're doing that water's heavy man and
they're giving you the shipping for free
just to get this cool water to your
house so go to liquiddeth.como
get that free shipping on all orders of
merch and water
and enjoy
just supporting good people from a good
company now let's get into it
all right man um
can i get a liquid death over here
certainly
what is that water right yeah it's just
watermelon can i have one yeah sparkling
or non-sparkling sparkling actually
please yeah dude i like sparkling water
you're a sparkly guy
all right ladies and gentlemen aaron
carter yeah dude what's up man
you are a wild man on a wild ride
you know that that seems pretty accurate
um
so
the last time i saw you would have been
when you were on dancing with the stars
is that right yeah and then we did uh we
did like a little cameo thing with um
the giant with the
wwf or something like that ah okay
we were we were both there and i think
that's when you actually got
like truly injured
wow oh you were there that night yeah i
i got slammed by the giant oh [ __ ]
andre the giant no and we saw each other
like briefly backstage but it was like
it was like what two seconds were you
talking about umaga when he [ __ ] yeah
i got [ __ ] up i got an umaga and then
the giant did it to me oh really yeah so
how was that for you he just that was
2006 when i was in the ring yeah www
yeah same time it it was painful like
you think it's like not real but
i mean you got a three four hundred
pound guy regardless if they're like
pretending it's still hurt it's still
funny yeah damn it still hurts man and
what that's oh six i mean how old are
you then like six stars was way after
that i was on dancing with the stars in
2009. how's that for you dude i
i don't want to talk bad about it
because the they were they were
wonderful
my experience was
terrible
my my experience was pretty terrible too
because
i didn't realize how much work actually
you had to put in i mean dancing and
practicing yeah they like for me when i
did it though i don't know about you but
for me when i did it
they already the dances were already a
minute and a half
and they shortened the time
for dances as the seasons progress i
think i i feel like i only had a minute
to do and then on mondays we would then
we would have to do two minute dances or
and two of them
it wasn't that
and then and then i took i i stole
karina smirnoff my partner from the
other guy on the show max and
schmidtkowski oh you you hooked up with
her
yeah yeah we we i basically stole her
like from him and then they broke off
their engagement and then and then
karina and i just didn't click and then
half like we were about to win
and then she got mad at me because i
basically didn't want to be i didn't
want to be like with her with her and
was like
stomping my feet on purpose during live
performances
like she was just and she would like
knee me in the balls real quick like you
know like
she was in the show yeah cause she just
didn't want to be on it anymore with me
and she was mad
and she's rushing and then i ended up
dating the russian later and oh my god
like russian women they're so beautiful
but man holy they will they will slice
your throat open have you ever uh
revealed that or is that an exclusive
for them
i got a lot of only exclusives just for
you guys
yeah you guys you reached out to us to
be on the podcast and dude i was super
surprised
i was i was i was super stoked i was
also super surprised because i wonder if
you know this but i got into tattooing
right i became a tattoo artist
like a couple years back yeah i i i
heard about it yeah i'm a very big fan
of you god damn i want to take the very
beginning though because i'm 33 you know
and i've been i've been doing this for
26 years yeah i appreciate that from the
very beginning i know about clown school
everything look right
so i get into tattooing a couple years
ago and it was right around the time
when you got this crazy face tattoo yeah
and uh and i saw that you were following
me on twitter so i hit you up i was like
yeah
i hit you up on twitter said um i missed
it i said uh yo yo dude i'm really good
at tattooing i even included in the dm
like my portfolio of to show like that
that i was actually doing good tattoos
yeah i wasn't like trying to tattoo your
face or anything but i was like
i promised you if you had your tattoo
gear here i would let you do a tattoo on
my face um
we'll come back yeah yeah we might want
to come back no no forever but the thing
was that when i sent the dms then all of
a sudden i was unfollowed by your
twitter account
so i don't know uh i i thought that i
had uh offended you or somehow like
i don't know
and and then that's that's that's kind
of strange here's what a sensitive
little petty
[ __ ] i am i'm like oh he hadn't
followed me i unfollowed him
so i thought we weren't birds anymore
you're like you know what [ __ ] aaron
carter stupid-ass twitter and and then
and then you reach out to to be on the
podcast i'm like [ __ ] right on dude i
would love to give you a tattoo i don't
know if i feel comfortable tattooing
your face but then again my philosophy
about tattooing is that uh i only wanna
to to work on people who are already
pretty
[ __ ] tatted up so that the stakes are
low yeah well you know your face
qualifies
i got my fiancee's name here i got three
moons crescent moons that represent you
know the three kids that i want to have
the love this stands for lion
um in finnish language because i'm
scandinavian finland french like the you
know what you said love and that's the
name of your that's the name of the
brand but see uh the way it's spelled
is actually means lion
so i that's why i have the lion here and
what do you mean the way it's spelled
[Music]
[Applause]
and i didn't i i didn't i did an album
called love
like this i got the neck tattoo um and
it was about a girl that i was dating
that was my backup dancer that basically
screwed me over and she did my video and
14 weeks pregnant she was 14 weeks
pregnant and then she didn't want to
have the baby so and then i wrote this
album to her as like you know all these
songs like you know just kind of sending
messages through music i didn't think it
would go anywhere really and then i
released a song called it was gold and
whatever but but back back to you know
the whole the whole love brand it's here
here there you know it's on my uh my
clothing line um it's it's just
it's just you know in this industry you
you really have to be a lion and and i i
have a lot of trolls especially since
which is really odd
since i've become
i'm i'm
four years sober now
um california's sober cali sober yeah so
only marijuana that's it uh so
and uh so i'm cali sober
and you know
got away from
the huffing duster and doing that and
that and it really ruined my body you
know i had to in the neurons and things
in my brain and i learned so much about
it and i have to take gabapentin three
times a day you know what's gabapentin
gabapentin it's a neurontin that helps
you with you know your receptors and
your brain from the damage that you do
from what happens if you don't take it
you have trouble like connecting words
and not necessarily um but
what i did makes me a high-risk seizure
because i was
doing uh huffing for like 10 years you
know you hiding it from the world
yeah i mean i did nitrous but you did uh
computer duster computer dust that dude
that's just like that's just like ten i
never did that it's almost like i don't
know about nitrous but i've done it
maybe once or something but like
i don't know i don't know have you ever
tried that i didn't i i was already
sober
before i found out about the computer
duster good good what what what's the
high feel like on that believe it or not
i have no idea what the high from
huffing computer duster is but boy can i
tell you about the high of stepping onto
a 1.7 million dollar tour bus with two
bathrooms six bunk beds a crate i mean
dude it's nuts the luxury inside this
thing is out of control but i can't
stand it because neither of the
bathrooms is equipped with the tushy ace
and what is the tushy ace oh my lord it
is the most luxurious bidet that your
butthole has ever heard of this thing
comes with a remote control that mounts
onto your bathroom wall right next to
your pooper and you get on it you push a
button and it warms up your butt to the
temperature you desire when you get done
taking your dump you push another button
and it starts blasting this refreshing
stream of water onto your butthole it's
like power
power washing power cleaning your
butthole nice and clean and then when
you get done doing that then you push
another button and it starts
it's just it blow dries at your butthole
dry
and then if you want to just take a
piece of toilet paper to just wipe and
see how clean your butthole really is go
ahead and do it but it's not even
necessary which is the best thing about
this product because it's like
environmentally friendly man i only just
learned about how toilet paper is really
a leading cause of the world's demise
and that's why hello tushie is the brand
to support and your butthole's gonna
love it you cannot get more luxurious
than the tushy ace i'm telling you and
you can get 10 off of it if you go to
hellotushy.com
hurry up while the holidays are popping
because if you want to get someone the
most luxurious gift ever it is the tushy
ace and again you can get 10 off if you
go to hellotushy.como
i have always said tushy is my favorite
sponsor of this podcast and i always
mean it so one more time go to
hellotushy.com
stevo and treat your butthole and the
buttholes of the people you love to the
tushy ace now let's talk about huffing
computer duster
it's like 15 20 seconds and you go right
back to normal but you're like but it's
the craziest euphoric like
high in the world and
it just it's like
you don't really like it
is it like
yeah yeah and
and
it's it's just it's really bad and it
ruined my insides and all this stuff and
then you know so
you know i was i dealt with a lot of uh
death my sister you know she she had
just dyed my full blood sister from a
drug overdose and then my dad died
a few years later
and you know went through some trauma i
released the album and the the year i
released the album was the year that i
went to allah house rehab center
and that and i had already been to betty
ford uh twice this is 2018. when you
release that um uh 2018 yeah 2018. yeah
so that's when i released it
and then i'm in rehab
and then you know i'm assigned to sony
and i kind of just
ruined everything for myself because
of
you know the disease of addiction and
it was really sad you know dealing with
that you know um
[Music]
not a lot of people who have if you
haven't been to rehab it's really hard
to understand or see through somebody
who's actually an addict or a current
currently using addict you know
ah i don't know i think it's kind of
evident to a lot of people if somebody's
loaded i'm so jealous of this i haven't
been able to think about anything since
my girl
wendy from peru
is cheating on me right now with scott
randolph that's how i feel about zelda
she loves scott god
um
so uh
when we were in your house and and dude
thanks for all the gear from your your
clothing line and the house tour and
showing me your assault rifle and
and jumping off your uh [ __ ] your
roof yeah
i mean that was quite the whirlwind tour
you just gave us um
and uh when we were in the house he said
that what you bought it like like a
number of years ago
bought this house exactly a year ago
for 6 20 and now
the area has gone up so it's selling for
9.50 right now
that is what's happening with real
estate i'm kicking myself that i haven't
done
i was flipped down this area is booming
a lot of people kind of put shade on on
the lancaster palmdale area but but guys
like okay i can ride 10 feet and then go
into
40 000 acres of legal riding trails and
suicide hills and all kinds of you know
whoopty dooms for like dirt biking
that yeah you chose to live out here
well i did this show called marriage
boot camp with my mom
and i got like two hundred thousand
dollars paid my agents uh you know paid
my mom money and i had like 120 left
over so i was about to go like buy a
lamborghini or something stupid i was
living in like an apartment and my mom
[ __ ]
excuse my language but uh can i cuss
yeah oh sure [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] um
no so she rips up the check and she's
like no and i was like what would you
just why'd you do that i want my mercy
to lock up right now and she's like
you're buying a house
i went and i bought a house that was
actually across the street from here and
i bought that house for 420 and then
sold it for 620 two years later after
being my first time so when you're a
first-time homeowner and this was the
first house i ever bought in my career
or anything
surprisingly because you know i made a
lot of money but i never made the right
decisions
and didn't have the right guidance
either and so
you know we i buy i purchased this house
my mom's like we're gonna move out to
lancaster because when we lived in
florida we used to come out to the
mojave desert and it's close to the
mojave desert and all that so come out
here and
i you know she's like purchased this
home you know and i i got got it for 420
and and
had to hold on to it for two years
before you can you can capital gains
yeah exactly correct and capital gains
so you can you know take houses and flip
them immediately
so now so that said that i wrote a
preventative if you sell it before
they'll tax you like twenty percent on
like you actually legally can't that's
just for the first time you buy a house
no for a first-time homeowner you have
to have it for two years oh yeah
if you're going through a hard money
loan and i was going through a hard
money loan with the 12 interest rate
because my credit was messed up and
you know three years taxes were paid
and all this stuff so i had to get all
this stuff squared away before i could
even buy a house
three years of taxes not paid like
that's pretty close to the cusp of like
pulling a
uh
wesley snipes and then anna the
situation oh right right right yeah the
situation was that i think i had this i
had to file for bankruptcy when i was uh
in in um
[Music]
because my parents didn't pay my taxes
when i was 12 13 and 14 and before i
turned 18 i grossed about 500 million
dollars
say that again
500 million by the time you're hauled
18.
[ __ ] because i've sold 75 million
records that's grossing yeah yeah so so
like yeah it's pretty crazy how you can
earn a lot of money and it all just goes
away yeah so the taxes on that's like
what two hundred dollars
how much money you're 38 in taxes 38 yes
i'm around yeah i always tax park at 50
yeah that's smart just keep it in your
head like only 50 percent as well well i
keep in my head absolutely especially
because we're in california and then
like
well here's well here's what i'm going
to do is now i'm going to i'm getting uh
i'm either going to sell this home and
get the price that i want or keep this
home pull the equity out and purchase a
house in colorado now i got all my taxes
squared away everything so now i can get
a 2.8 interest hra loan
and i'm i can you know have my primary
residency in a place like colorado not
vegas a lot of people go to vegas
because of the taxes that's why they go
to but i'm going to go to colorado and
get like this big 48 acre beautiful
ranch you know bart yeah because what
part of what part um i mean i've been
looking to like tell your ride and
areas like that sounds peaceful more
peaceful than vegas probably well yeah i
don't i'm not into strip clubs i'm not
into stuff like that yeah vegas is tough
i'm more of a southern southern boy you
know yeah i wonder if you've got t-pain
beat because that we were talking to
t-pain about how he blew through 30
million bucks and then like got to a
point where he couldn't afford a whopper
wow and you're dude i've gotten there
multiple times right
now i'm talking about like hundreds of
millions of dollars like but but but the
thing was unfortunately and you know
my dad's not here but my mom's alive man
i love you mom i know you'll watch this
but like
they didn't handle things correctly your
mom was your manager my mom is not my
manager she was though she was yeah she
was so she left the job of the business
management accounting to my dad
and he messed it up and he wasn't
putting the 15 of the paul peterson
coogan law money into my account
paul peterson coogan law so paul
peterson was an act child actor that
created the the law
that put makes you have to put 15 of
your children's money
if they're actors singers whatever
well yeah well because parents end up
blowing all that money because the
parents just like they take hold of it
otherwise when i turned eighteen i would
have lived in low hands
and then been basically like a slave did
you see what they spent it on really so
legally of course i did my dad bought
four different race boats that were
worth millions of dollars he was a
professional race boat driver
we had four tour buses h3 prevos um we
had 15 golf carts uh we had over
45 cars 50 dogs
three yachts over 70 feet um a football
field did you talk about fifteen houses
my cribs episodes fifteen houses
like yeah you did look like old cribs
these houses yeah
yeah fifteen houses
yeah right how close together were they
well they were all of our neighbors
houses and my dad wanted to create a
compound so he just made a bunch of
noise until they kicked out
wow
back to this uh freddy krueger law like
um paul peterson okay paul peterson
kruger
coogan
they uh they made a law
so that like
to
limit the amount of a child star's money
the parents can blow
to 85
right right right you can only blow
eighty-five percent of your home you can
only steal eighty-five percent of your
kid's earnings it's crazy and you know
what i actually have been petitioning
and working on something called the
carter law which actually makes you have
to put 30 of the kids money into an
account and then they get it in
increments 18 and then 25 and they have
to graduate certain business type
schools in order to gain their money
whoa so they know how to manage their
finances so they're going to pull that
up yeah that's not a bad idea
especially the incremental because like
yeah
yeah an 18 year old like you know here's
30 million dollars yeah it's like oh i
blew through five million dollars in
like a year yeah it's crazy how quick
you can spend i think i heard about mike
tyson like one year he made 400 million
but he spent 500 million that year or
something like that i think that mike uh
it was more of a 300 million dollar
situation across the
gnarly
that's insane i mean i i i like hardcore
where did you go like
you know
tell me about this erin carter a lot
because i i'm very interested in that i
think uh
they think you're onto something i think
so too where like
you uh
the child star
earns earning millions of dollars
and then they have to do certain things
to unlock like correct accounting 101
class the local community college
exactly how how brilliant is that really
because i'm speaking from personal
experience so if i go if i if i look at
things in retrospect and i say okay i'm
18 years old
i get i have six million dollars waiting
for me give me two million and then
by the time
you know
25 comes along seven years later
then
you know i have to take
you know three months of business
finance schooling in order to learn
about 401ks social security and and you
know
housing and invest proper investments so
then by that time okay you blew your
money but then 25 comes along and you're
like okay i messed up i learned now i
need to buy a house
i mean the tough part for that is that
once someone's 18 they're an adult they
can do whatever they want
i'm not going to school but imagine it
being put out in three different you
know 18 25 and 30. so
in in i mean if you're gonna do that you
might as well keep keep it
keep it staggered out i would be super
stoked but it would also be making them
money if it was put into proper accounts
because it would be gaining interest
while they're waiting for right when uh
people join the nfl and i think certain
other sports leagues they like make them
take classes do they really just because
athletes it's like an epidemic of people
going broke
i think that i think they might have to
shaq doing something like that too we
talked about that with him right there's
this crazy um
documentary called broke which is just
about athletes that made hundreds of
millions of dollars that sounds good the
statistics are insane where like
90 of nba players are completely broke
within five years of their
nba career ending wow
sounded like some like whatever maybe
getting it wrong but well i mean i i
think i think i am on to something when
it comes to that you know and it's you
know something that that that's uh
it's for them and it's a part of my
legacy too you what was uh i i seem to
recall there was something where you
were telling uh justin bieber like to be
careful
like with that
you know like like you could lose it all
and you were kind of trying to be a
mentor and then he got like kind of
nasty with you
ah justin bieber he is a successful man
but you know what
i'm getting pretty successful too and so
can you how become your own boss of an
e-commerce empire how do you do it one
word baby ship station what's that
that's this one place where you use one
interface to bring all of your shipping
needs regardless of where you're
shipping from if you're using amazon
your own website etsy you name it it's
all brought into one interface and you
get like the rates that are saved
normally for like fortune 500 companies
you get the best rates for your shipping
and you know how i know this because the
co-host of the wild ride podcast scott
randolph runs my warehouse and my whole
shipping operation could we do it
without ship station god no you buy this
shirt at stevo.com we're gonna buy the
labels through ship station that's right
that's right and you know what these
people are nuts they love me so much and
they love you for listening to my
podcast so much that they're gonna give
you a free 60-day trial you don't have
to pay anything to enjoy the benefits of
ship station and how crazy are they to
be giving you this offer with the
holidays coming up you sign up right now
for free you get to try this for 60 days
how do you do that you go to
shipstation.com and then you look in the
top right corner of their website
there's a little microphone you click
that you plug in the promo code stevo
and you're off and running just in time
to handle all of your holiday shipping
needs no matter how big or small your
business is and my business got pretty
big we use shipstation we only use
shipstation and even if your business is
tiny you're still going to get better
rates than anywhere else it's going to
be easier to use and you're going to
have a better more successful operation
so don't turn down this offer go to
shipstation.com hit that microphone in
the top right corner and type in the
promo code stevo get your 60-day free
trial that's 60 days of hassle-free
stress-free shipping and just get
successful like me and justin bieber
yeah dude ship station make ship happen
now let's talk about justin bieber being
a jerk
yeah you know justin bieber and i we
have a very peculiar relationship like
he hit me up on instagram
and he was like oh you know come over
and hang out to my house and i was like
actually no you can come over from mine
i got four wheelers and so i'm not
trying to just sit around look at
artwork
you know
come over to my house i got four
wheelers atx's and bikes and we can go
ride around and actually you know have
some fun you know and then
when was that that was you know a year
ago
so and then there was an incident when
he was being a little [ __ ] i told
him on twitter i said if i see him i'll
punch you in your face
so how long ago was that uh like maybe
like
six seven years ago i don't know
something like that like he's doing you
guys are cool now
no we're not cool we're not no when i
invited you over there
i'm i'm i'm his competitor man like yeah
like but a year ago he asked you to come
over yeah and i said no
and so when's the last time you talked
to him since then
i i don't really have anything to say to
justin bieber yeah i don't know like you
know he uh he scooter braun
um you know it was it was very
interesting because when i released my
love album i did a billboard article
and then the next day
after i hadn't bitten out
with music for like 10 years
aaron rosenberg justin bieber's
entertainment attorney was asked a
question of course he approves all the
questions you know how it goes
how did you get justin bieber to not
turn out like aaron carter
wow
and that was a question that was asked
to justin bieber's entertainment
attorney and i was livid because i had
just done a great article with them the
day before about my coming back as
basically like a new artist that's
producing his music and not being
puppeted and doing it himself and
that that really hurt that really hurt
to see that and
to see like the boycotting because
there's this underlining smear campaign
cancel culture troll
boycott
thing that we're all going through
everybody that's in this industry i'm
sure you're going through it too if i'm
wrong i'm wrong you know tell me go [ __ ]
myself well getting boycotted
smear campaigns cancer cultures trolls
people making up lies doxing you um you
know
now that i've now that i've started to
really just get my life together it's
like i feel like people are trying to
bring me back down to where i was before
and
i'm not that person anymore you know i'm
i'm engaged i'm about to have a baby on
the way you know it's time to be a dad
and it's literally like a matter of a
couple days huh what yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah literally
one for the baby to be born
his name is
prince michael lyric carter
congrats yeah i'm wearing this michael
jackson shirt well because michael
jackson i beat his guinness book of
world records when i was 10 years old
for being the youngest male solo artist
to have four consecutive uh singles in
the top ten billboard charts wow michael
jackson then reached out to my mom and
said hey i want to give your son the
title of prince of pop you can use that
my mom wrote a book called prince of pop
and then i did
a song with michael jackson he picked a
handful of people luther vandross celine
dion beyonce
justin timberlake and me
and we did a song called what more can i
give and then i opened up within madison
square garden on september 9th september
10 of 2001 and we all left the morning
of september september 11th and i saw
the plane hit the building like you're
in a plane no i was in a limousine i was
i was supposed to go on tour and michael
invited us to go to an amusement park
after the show so i was in the limousine
going to a private airport i was across
the hudson and i was just standing there
like thinking oh i remember this from
like home alone you know and i was just
thinking you know whatever and then all
of a sudden i see the plane hit and
about four seconds later i hear it
and it was just
it was crazy and then so i i saw michael
at the concert and i go
hey i'm gonna get that jacket from you
okay he had that sparkly jacket on the
red one no no the one that's made out of
all swarovski crystal that's worth like
35 million dollars
now um there's only the right one to ask
for uh and i was like i was like i'm
gonna get i was like
i was like i'm gonna get that [ __ ]
review he kind of get glued it off a
little bit then i went to his birthday
party and you know his 47th birthday
party and i i literally just grabbed the
cake and i smashed in his face i didn't
care i was like i'm gonna treat you like
a human being you know what i mean did
you get the the jacket later that night
me my brother rodney jerkins michael and
raffle the executor of his estates and
we're all sitting down in his living
room and raffles
lanes over mike and goes hey don't you
have something for aaron
he comes out gives me the jacket nick
gets so pissed off he gets up
immediately and leaves
wow that's amazing wait this is because
now on 9 11. you were on your way on
your way to the airport
yeah this was just a matter of like
three or four different incidents
where we were together
um
what was your take on uh
on like all the the michael jackson
documentary neverland yeah that was that
[ __ ] [ __ ] man wade robson bro
come on dude
i'm like i'm sorry but i was there
i spent plenty of nights with michael
i didn't see anything remotely close to
that
but i saw nothing about respect and gen
and
and generosity
sure when i left
that neverland
i came back
uh because we used to live next door to
michael um in san diego nets
we had a ranch out there but not at this
time
i leave get in the limo after his
birthday party ride his dirt bike around
i smoked weed with michael
um did he smoke a lot of weed is there
michael jackson
i've never heard of michael smoking weed
actually that's michael jackson's
supposed to read and i smoked me with
him
so that's a good one so and then
so i get but here's the craziest part
about all this i get
back to the universal sheraton
right
and my parents had four
fbi agents and detectives there to talk
to me
and they're like did michael do anything
do
and i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you guys talking about
what year was this yeah how long ago was
that i mean
i don't even remember he was still alive
joe joe right no he he remembers
he was probably still alive
yeah yeah
but to be honest with you no no but to
be real he was struggling and we all
know that
sure
it's it's it's it's not you know no
it's not new news well how old are you
at that time
um like 13 or like 18. uh i was 16 16
15. and you went you slept over at his
place it was placed multiple times yeah
yeah are there other kids there at the
time
so it's just you you're just hanging all
day stay the night yeah i mean i think
it got to a point where because i
literally you know i'm pretty candid
i'll ask anybody anything i'll give [ __ ]
man like whatever
i i literally asked myself so what's up
with all this like little kid stuff
going on with you you know like why do
they do that to you he's like
he's like i don't know but i all i try
to do is is
reinstall myself
into new generations so that i keep
myself current
and i also never really had a childhood
so these when i hang out with these kids
they
they they give me a feeling of like you
know fulfilling a void
in my heart he told me and i was like
well then why don't you keep doing he's
like because they won't stop prosecuting
me
they won't stop all these mothers that's
what i'm trying to tell you is when i
left my parents had fbi agents and
detectives there to try to sue michael
and i said no no no no no no get the
hell out of here all these [ __ ] guys
and
and then they left and then my parents
were all pissed off because they wanted
to do it on purpose
do you understand what i'm saying
sure they wanted to i don't find that
too
like your parents were interested in
suicide
they wanted to sue him because they
wanted to make up a lie because of what
was going on with all the prosecutions
what do you do with michael when you're
just kicking it with them are you guys
like smoking a joint yeah
we went me me michael and chris tucker
went riding around on four-wheelers in
the mountains for like three or four
hours um you know michael jumped into
the uh his alligator pit and started
swinging around his alligator tail in
the middle of the day like he was just a
goofy fun guy man you know and if you
treated him like a person you didn't
have you know uh
and know like star struck or whatever
and people are people man like i've met
everybody you know like i've had elton
john come to multiple concerts of mine
and i didn't even know at that time you
know like i've i've
my dad was best friends with bruce
willis like you know like he would come
over all the time i went to rumors bruce
brought me in to do rumors sweet 16. you
know um it's just
i just i've met so many people that
along the way you know that that's just
you know it is what i mean i i i dated
mel b from spice girls for you know
oh i never knew that and we used to tour
together when i was nine and she was 20
my girl loves the spice girls
yeah dude
um
so
when uh
when you make 500 million dollars and
your dad doesn't even put 15
into a special account for you
is it like
you made all this money and you didn't
even get to blow it yourself like other
people blew it well i mean that's 75
million dollars that was supposed to go
into my account
enough not not five
what i got
so uh when you so is there any ever any
like legal action against like your your
parents no because when the when all of
a sudden 2014
25 24 25 26 years i don't remember
exactly but
i get hit with a bankruptcy or liens and
they garnish my wages and i was like
broke i completely broke at the time
doing this off broadway show called the
fantasticks for two years trying to just
rebuild my accountability as a you know
a performer
then they garnished my wages i only made
654 dollars a week 80 bucks a night and
then they garnished that and i only then
in new york city i was only making 312
dollars a week and
and then my lawyer jan michael morris
was like
you know you're gonna probably get like
on the chapter 11 or 13 or something
like that he says by the graces of god
you'll get a chapter seven but it's
probably not going to happen
which means i had to pay 11 chapter 11
would be 25 cents on the dollar chapter
is 50 cents on on the dollar that you
got to pay how much did you owe i owed
over 8 million dollars
and from stemming from 2001 two and
three
damn so at eight when i was a little kid
at 600 a week on broadway that's a
lifetime to pay back
at that point i just was like i'm
screwed and i called my brother nick and
i asked him i said yo can i have fifteen
hundred dollars to retain jan
to start this bankruptcy thing and nick
was like oh you got to go to therapy
three times a week and you have to pay
for it yourself and i'm like uh i can
only make 300 a week what do you want me
to eat out of trash cans i said i
already have to wait outside of a deli
at 3am to wait for the guys to give me
bacon so like you know ma'am
um
and he said no my brother said no though
he was like no no you got to do this and
you say no and i was like and he told me
to rot in jail he hung up on me and
man
so and then and then and then i went to
the courts paid the money
got them taken care of on my own how did
you get the money uh i ended up getting
a bonus that month for if i sold out the
whole show for the month i would get 30
000 so i got thirty thousand dollars and
then i had to pay for my sister's
funeral and for my that month and for my
bankruptcy
and
um we go in
and my my attorney general michael
morris was like hey you know all you
have to do is get a judgment against
your mom and dad they'll go to prison
you'll have to pay a dime i said i would
never do that to my parents so i don't
care what they've done wrong they've
given me this career this life
and i'm gonna do good things and i'm
gonna rebuild my career so i went to the
judge personally he's an incredible
litigator and i walked up to my story
and the judge was like hey just sign
these papers and it's not on you and i
said nope
i told him right to say i said i'll pay
the 50 cents on the dollar he goes
because you said that i'm giving you a
chapter seven bam you have a full
discharge
everything is getting paid off for you
for free you don't owe anything and you
don't have credit score goes back up to
700 because of what you just said to me
so just a clean wipe you're down to just
because zero i
would i told the judge i would never put
my parents in prison did you ever talk
to your mom about it like did she
like what does she say about it like
about that arrow when all that money is
coming in and you know she didn't she
didn't really have the time to uh
account for it and do it because she was
with me and i was a little kid you know
i was pre-teen teen adult you know and
she was with me the whole time so it
wasn't it was my dad's job to handle the
finances not my mom's it was never her
fault yeah we're like dad three yachts
no i was like
my
my dad was a military policeman and on
my 18th birthday
i told him he's like oh you owe me 300
000 of commissions after i got my trust
fund money and i told him no and he
pinned me down on the ground and took
his 44 magnum and shot it right next to
my right ear and i'm deaf in my right
ear because of that
that's what happened to me on my 18th
birthday
are there any advantages to being deaf
in your right ear
no
actually yeah actually maybe one you're
right producing and producing like high
hat frequency levels like i can hear
what they're supposed to sound like so
i'll plug this ear and i can hear what
they're like kind of like supposed to be
mixed
like so
what like it cuts out the height
my equilibrium gets a little off and i
run into things
you know because yeah because it's gone
and then it makes it and then i'm
already have loss of hearing from fans
and performing you said your your love
album you mixed it yourself i produced
it i wrote it um andrew wepper mixed it
with mastered it
uh executive produced the project and i
funded it gotcha okay i was gonna say
mixing with only one year would be
[ __ ] hard
we put on like a youtube video while we
were driving here
and uh just kind of randomly it's it
showed you saying you know that but like
your dad fired the gun and you're
was it was it called aaron aaron carter
being psychotic for 10 minutes or
something no
you watched those videos hell no
it wasn't weird man they make they they
say things on you when you're on live to
try to get you to clip you and they make
their 14 28 cents a month and whatever
right right right exactly exactly like
i mean it was definitely like a hit job
video there's no question about that oh
was it oh okay yeah the uh
job video
but uh they showed you saying i'm deaf
in my right ear and then it was like a
photo sequence like
and it was all photos of you talking on
the phone like holding it up to your
right ear like you know presumably like
hearing the call
like uh
just
so you can kind of hear in your right
ear
i mean
it's like 75 percent gone so
naturally i'm a righty so i do that but
then usually i have to go to speaker
phone
so
i usually talk on speakerphone all the
time so fair enough you know yeah and
dude they're always trying to like
debunk things like
i i
kind of kind of alluded to the fact that
you were coming here right before you
got here right you said that they were
telling you yeah and they were like
you're a liar stephen ain't coming over
there laughing my ass off they and they
and everybody always thinks that they
don't think i own my houses then i show
them my deeds and then they still don't
think i own it they don't think i own
all my four cars and i and i'm like i
show them they don't they still they
it's just it's weird like jealousy type
of things and i mean it's an impossible
thing to be trying to prove it yeah but
like yeah you know here's the deal
so i'm born since you know on december
7th i'm a purifier signed double cancer
moon and i will fight you to the [ __ ]
death and i will win i will actually
destroy you
i mean there's there's there's no
question i don't even have to use my
hands
there's no question whatsoever that
you've definitely made some outrageous
claims like you know and uh and i like
how you're candid about it you say like
you know i'm i'm i'm not particularly
humble i'm kind of narcissistic and i
deserve to be i like that that that line
you know it's like you've pulled off
some awesome stuff in your life you
deserve to to feel like you're the man
right well i'll tell you why steve steve
always because
it's because when when you go so many
years
when you're out and you're down and
people are are laughing at you and
humiliating you publicly and it's in the
kind of spectrum that we deal with
you know
with every type of individual you can
think of
once once you do fix your life right
like we did
we're proud of it and we want we're
grateful for it proud grateful right and
i'm also very i i feel a lot more humble
too you know as time goes on but at the
same time i'm like yo
don't disrespect me because you don't
know how hard the work was for me to get
to where i am today sure and so yeah i
am proud of these things yeah i am proud
because without you guys
also i wouldn't be able to have this
stuff the fans the fans are our boss
they're our family but they're to me and
they're but our they're our bosses you
know because they pay us right you know
so i want to show to them hey
look i i i've worked really hard the
last four years to change my life around
i've stayed clean and sober off of
huffing
every single day since i graduated from
rehab being there for 90 days
and that's something
that i i find that you know the general
public or media doesn't shine light on
they want me to be the villain
i'm naturally a villain so you don't
have to i have a nickname they call me
the joker right because i've been
bullied
so much
right so
i'm the joker bro if if people want to
play
with me you won't play with my emotions
i'm gonna paint my face and i'm gonna
show you who's boss i'm gonna scare the
[ __ ] out of you because
you you pissed me off and you you
people can
people on instagram live and all these
platforms
they're being [ __ ] man they're not
doing anything about it they're acting
like they're ignoring it when they
really need to be calling out these
people and making holding them
accountable i think that that what i'm
hearing from you is is a
a a good strong argument for just not
paying attention to like comments and
stuff because like with like people like
you and i we have enough people
following us yeah that there's of course
there's gonna be people talking [ __ ] in
there like if i like i i'm never gonna
win if i go through reading all the
comments no no i don't read that it's
more so when i like go on instagram you
know and then the live comments and i'm
like listening to my music and i'm
trying to promote something and then
they're on there saying oh you look like
you have aids or you're dying you're a
crackhead you're huffing again you you
know
and then just
you know except and it's back to back to
back to back all from these smear
campaign bot accounts but you know what
i'm talking about with about accounts
yeah i don't really do lives but what i
do but if you did you'd see
what i do do now is uh i go on the live
chat for when we premiere the episode of
the podcast on youtube
so uh yeah that'd be cool if you went on
the live chat for this one when it
premieres oh well
oh
do you have a you have a book coming out
soon still working on it but i actually
changed my uh formula of how i want to
do it so the way i want to write my book
is i want to write it with my bare hands
and my handwriting yeah from me
personally and then have that published
with actually my handwriting hmm
damn dude my hand would get so scary
it's going to be tough i think it's
going to be a very different like i
don't know what's your take on that's
kind of cool i would be okay with that
however like you know there's so much
edit i just finished my second book and
um
i think that the only way to accomplish
what you're talking about would be to
work it out and you know
finalize it with the editor and then
once you've got the the exactly the
final write it out then write it yeah
yeah agree because because you don't
want to like try to actually people are
going to be reading it in cursive or
whatever how good is it however
girls got good cursive but not dudes
yeah so while we were driving here paul
looked up uh looked you up on spotify
and and what would what was the one that
was like a recent traffic light
91 million bro i was like
dude that's sick thank you that's huge
thank you brother one album
one song streaming on spotify that's
just on spotify that song has over 250
million on all platforms phenomenal dude
congratulations
and i was blown away i was like i cannot
believe this worked after going through
all this hell and bankruptcy and
off-broadway and you know making no
money and waiting for bacon outside of a
deli to just eat at 3 o'clock in the
morning you know because of starving and
i can't believe that i was able to write
this love project you know
and it was dedicated to a girl that i
was madly in love with that didn't love
me back and she was my dancer for two
years
and
i just i was it was profound i released
a song called fool's gold
and she was she's actually the girl in
my music video
and we did it on valentine's day she
also made me pay her four grand to do it
so which was
whatever
um and then like one time i caught on
she told told a friend on facebook
friends like oh why are you with aaron
carter she's like it's good for my
resume
when did that song drop that song
dropped in 2018.
so [ __ ] a man that's killer yeah yeah
and then i still have an active 900 000
listeners a month phenomenal did you get
paid good off uh spotify
or not uh no i'm actually
um currently about to sue sony for a lot
of money because they owe me about 1.3
million dollars
so so that sony can expect their lawsuit
soon that album came out
brad paisley sued him for 12.3 million
dollars and won so i'm going to hire
ryan paisley's attorney see you
soon there you go do we want to air that
mm-hmm
sure i gotta imagine i don't care
i mean i don't know and then saying
anything about allah's gonna change the
the fact that the defamation of
character yeah and it's the facts i know
the numbers and i know the facts and i
know how many hats i wore in the project
for i don't know what i'm entitled to
i've already done the math i'm not
stupid
you know i don't jump into a water
unless i know how deep it is literally
we saw it yeah yeah
well especially your house too i like
this guy over here so so you got a new
single dropping yeah and and uh and
you're gonna go talk to dr drew about it
yeah when's that yeah um that's gonna be
on monday monday dr drew is my bro
why are you talking to drew about a
single you're dropping
it's a combo because he's it's got four
years of sobriety and
and so much to say is about my siblings
it's about um
angel
and nick and what they put me through
and nine restraining orders trying to
get a 5150 on and what's the status and
all the restraining orders now they're
gone they're gone
yeah
the judges told them absolutely not
you're not getting the first time they
gave him they gave him a tro i got nine
restraining orders they took you know
nine of my firearms away from me three
of my ars two of my shotguns all my pit
mine nine millimeter pistols my throat
my m1a 308.
dude we could make a
insane
episode of uh of my tattoo show i would
love to do it
we can ride bikes because
we're talking about
the ar
can you imagine melting it down that's
just substantial
he wants to melt down the gun and shove
it up his ass
and you're not doing that
that's a lot to fit up your ass
well you know what if it was up your
butt you'd know it
maybe a glock but not an ar maybe a
glock
it just struck me now that like wow i
might be trying to bite off more than i
can chew no i i think the tattoo thing
would be great actually yeah dude i
actually want something else on the
other side what do you match up
here's the thing though
if if we only understood love we
wouldn't we wouldn't know what hate is
if we only understood hate what
we wouldn't
you know or we can talk about it or it
could be something maybe not love love
not love
i don't know i think i'm pretty much
done with my face tattoos like i
and here's the thing i'm not a
soundcloud rapper bro
like every album i release you know
sells millions so
it's just a part i'm comfortable with my
identity and that's the name of my new
album it's called identity so back to dr
drew you know it's so much to say is
about them and all this stuff and about
my siblings and now it's actually like a
country trap pop song
that's cool so is that the first of its
kind
i mean there's someone like it like me
if it's kind there you go
so and then the rest of the records got
it's all
real things like saying how i'm not
perfect and there's another song called
apologize to my family that i did i mean
and
now i just got to record them i've been
going through
the project i found an incredible
producer morgan matthews my best friend
brian cassidy is writing it he's on
house arrest right now though for
written threat to kill but he's writing
it so um
so something to say is about your
relationship with your siblings yep
the restraining orders are gone yep um
but like i saw some like pretty wild
stuff with the
the
the accusations against your brother
nick yeah and all the like police
reports and this and i backed it up
though you know what and you know what
to be honest did anything come of that
did uh no he couldn't sue me for season
to sister slander because well right now
i'm saying did anything come of the
accusations no no uh and you know what
listen uh when it comes to that
i don't like it i don't like what i
heard what i seen and what i saw and
you know my mama's boy
and i just feel like
that
i backed it up with factual evidence so
it is what it is but at the same time
i'm like
should i have done that you know it's an
aggressive move
but but here's the thing i was pissed i
was really pissed at nick because for so
many years he wanted me to get on my
feet and buy a house and all this stuff
and when i did he did not give me the
words of affirmation or accolades and he
didn't say i'm proud of you and
something as simple as that
coming from a family member when you
have such a broken family means a lot
and then also he
you know just
kind of just shunned me over like my
whole adult life you know house carter's
he faked to fight or faked a fight you
know it was a fake fight what on the
show yeah do you ever see that thing
well you know how i know it's fake
and how everyone else should know
he had a blanket over his head and all
the lights were on
and you claim to be sleeping with all
the lights on and blanket over your head
and the camera filming you
and you're like
you got all your lights on no that's not
how someone goes to sleep brother
they gonna say put the lights off do you
guys talk now i mean was last night no
we don't speak at all the last time they
spoke to me
was
horrible because they had the
restraining orders and legally they can
reach out to me and i can't reach out to
them i can't even respond and written
and this is what happens three months
later after the restraining orders on
christmas day when they knew i was alone
and i celebrate all my holidays alone
i'm
lonely on christmas day
whatever just watching home alone i'm
just trying to enjoy myself and
i get two emails back to back from angel
who had a restraining order against me
and nick
and then they said oh we love you so
much merry christmas
time heals everything
right but that
that that's what my brother said to me
after he said oh allegedly you know
aaron wants to kill my wife an unborn
baby
and then takes pictures of me
unloading my guns out of my car at my
last address
and then takes it into court and says
and has his attorney say look at aaron's
uh you know in vegas unloading his guns
and then my attorney goes your honor
aaron's address is in the back of the
picture
in california
and
so it's it's such a complicated
situation it really is and that's
something i want to talk to doctor drew
about
yeah is that that's who i i want to say
hey dr drew
what do you think in your your realm of
expertise as a doctor not a tv
personality
what do you think because
you know
i
apologize to my brother and i'll say
that right now it's the first time
for
letting his skeletons out of my closet
okay because
and letting the skeletons out of his
closet because i'm the kind of human
being that i like to be held accountable
for my actions
if i do something wrong i'll tell you
i'm doing it wrong
or you'll just you'll know and then i'll
admit it to you you know i don't lie
does he know you're having a baby
of course they haven't reached out but
they sent these messages right but
i would never talk to nick ever again if
i heard a rumor
from an ex-girlfriend that i broke up
with that out that nick wanted to kill
melanie and our unborn baby that's about
to be here in seven days i would never i
would never send him a christmas message
i'm just you just be cut bro but here's
the thing if i had responded to angel's
message she's that she sent
or nix
2.5 years for each one
in jail
what if you break your restraining order
at that time i would that would be
yesterday the strainer
three years but so are you saying
and then they email me and if i and then
if i responded
i sent it to my attorney she says
unfortunately they know that they can
send messes to you and that you cannot
reciprocate anything or else each
message you respond to is 2.5 years in
jail damn right are you saying you you
understand where nick is coming from
that if someone told you that and you
believed it
you know
that you would you would probably react
the same way
no i'm saying like he's saying that nick
sent him a christmas message after no
that i get that again but you're saying
like if someone told you keep it off the
internet like yeah like come on dude why
are you putting it on the internet
you know right before i went to rehab
he tweeted oh if you need root hub hope
after i got
arrested for a dui
and then that got dropped i didn't get
to have a dui because it wasn't driving
under the influence i just hadn't been
asleep for two days and i was driving to
the next venue in alabama he tweets oh
if you need help in rehab let me know
dude come on right don't tweet and then
i said to him i said why did you tweet
that oh i didn't have your number okay
then dm it bro
yeah like don't put it out there to make
yourself look like this knight in
shining armor for sure and that you're
superior to everybody else in your
family just because and
sorry nick but
bro
you've had like three felonies homie
what are his felonies he's had like four
duis oh yeah
like
you know
he he
he allegedly beat up paris hilton
oh damn you know
i wasn't there around i was there but i
didn't see that but
that's what she claimed
and she put it out to the world
you know
and so a lot of his behavior i didn't
like i don't like i don't i didn't like
how he always tried to act like a father
figure but wasn't and tried to act like
a brother but didn't know how to be a
brother you know and then i dealt with
so much bullying and torturing when i
grew up like they were throwing me in
water moccasin pits and you know
take me 75 miles an hour tubing like and
you know the danger of this kind of
stuff like
75 miles an hour tubing
i had to fall off you're gonna stop
putting a chicken in your jaw
alligator pits but my first ever surgery
was from a tubing accident [ __ ] really
there you go
there you go i didn't break anything i
had a hematoma in my leg and they had to
open it up to yeah
that's that square right wow
okay so i was going pretty good i was
probably doing 70 75 something 60 70
yeah it was when they whipped it and and
uh because if you're on the tube your
legs are hanging off
kevo
david
my buddy camo and uh because i was like
oh steve thinks he's a stunt man
wouldn't
have it and then when they when you whip
like you go around faster and like my
leg hit like a log in the water or
something oh you hit a log i mean
because even just the water waters we
were in the cars bro so like they're
like doing that like there's coral reefs
around there's you know
[Music]
it it could slice you open a little bit
and then you know
you all of a sudden you'll have the
lemon sharks and the bull sharks right
on your ass
you know
uh
you know shark diving is it's we would
get on the front of like the carolina
skiffs and we would jump on the on a
lemon shark and flip them over and
paralyze them throw them in the boat and
eat them damn um if your brother was
here would you ever do a podcast with
your brother to hash things out or is it
a lot deeper than that he would never do
it he stayed he he does the silent game
he trolls me so hard he just released a
song when he knows i'm releasing a song
when i was doing the boxing thing he was
posting pictures of him doing boxing
when i came back out after the
fantastics and i started touring again
and making
good money
i i had a song
album called aaron's party so i called
that the tour of the after party well
nick just got finished doing a tour
called the after party so he's non-stop
copying and trolling his little brother
and bro you're 42 years old
leave it alone
obviously we don't get along obviously
you know i'm going to be 34
in less than a month
and
there is there is no reconciliation to i
i'm not even asking for an apology
because they try to get a 50 150 on me
mm-hmm steve had that yeah i had that
steve had a 52-50 yeah yeah i did
50 150 is a 72-hour involuntary
psychiatric hole 52.50 is a two-week
wow voluntary
that's what happens when you show up for
you when they process you in for your
51.50 and you spit on people and trying
to throw furniture they change you to
52.
you get the upgrade
okay
get an upgrade yeah
yeah well i mean it was crazy because i
you know and then and then i saw like
i was going on live instagram live a lot
and just you know
you know doing no adam 20 uh no i uh uh
no jumper out on 22 and vlad tv and
doing just different things those were
legendary interviews yeah and i got more
coming up i got on the 29th to interview
i'm doing with vlad tv again cool and
then i'm reaching out to do you know um
no jumper again and then he had the adam
22 guy yeah
he was a little bit combative
i agree yeah i agree i agree i agree
that they all are trying to get under my
skin for the most part besides yeah
besides you you've been the only one
that actually i'm not trying to get
under anybody's skin or like you know
my life is controversial though
i think it's it i think it's fascinating
you know i think it's fascinating like
the the phenomena of hearing your
interviews have have been
like they they've been they've been
they've been the logan paul one was
particularly thankful yeah picked
particularly crazy yeah it was because
that's when they first revealed about
all the stuff with the rape stuff
allegations with my brother i was on
logan paul yeah yeah yeah that that i
mean and then i gave him my chain and i
got his chain
and then uh but i like i like the guy i
think i think those guys are did you see
that like they're after the fact their
their appraisal of uh
like they said that the the the pendant
on the chain you gave them had real
diamonds yeah but that the necklace
had fake diamonds on it yeah i i don't i
don't i don't know why he said that
that's definitely not true um because i
brought a presidium diamond tester and
tested this time it's right in front of
him on the show
so and then he gave me a necklace that i
found out from sunny the jeweler it only
cost five thousand hey uh he said that
it had been appraised at fifteen when he
gave you he's a liar i talked to sonny
the jeweler that's the guy who made it
five thousand dollars it cost to make
that close yeah
sorry so uh
i like logan paul me too i like luggage
me too i love i love what they've been
able to do and they're they're very they
have a good work ethic and they work
hard dude insane work ethic yeah you
know fantastic for you like
does
you know like the feeling of success
at such a young age so much success but
you were kind of like
probably pretty used to it at like nine
or so like
how does success feel differently now
when you put out an album yourself and
you get like 99 91 million streams
is that do you kind of realize like oh
this is what like what does it feel like
as a kid what does it feel like now it
feels like
i'm proud of it because it's my body of
work
you know it's not
you know like somebody else's tattoo
that did it to you you know it's like
you did the tattoo on yourself or
something yourself the gratification
behind that is completely
different and it's
the juxtaposition is just crazy from
having an album that other producers do
and then when you do your own body of
work but here's here's the caveat
that
now this album is being produced by
morgan matthews and written by my best
friend
in florida who's been on house arrest
for eight eight months right now for
written threat to kill so like you know
that's a writer
yeah
he's got a lot of time on his hands yeah
but the guy's in prison for her house
arrest for written threat to kill is the
writer of your album yes so it's going
to kill my best friend it's going to
count it's writing a lot he's got a
murderer
okay so when you did the boxing thing uh
was that like a huge payday like every
people seem to be making a ton of money
on the boxing thing nope
nope i got 15 000
i found out that lamar got 40 but i'm
done with celebrity boxing that's an
exclusive damon we're no longer doing
business um because i just i just got a
deal to fight
somebody bigger for 60k you did okay
with a different with fight tv with a
different company
so that's what you get damon for playing
people short because i brought more
ratings than you've ever had
i think uh that's my narcissistic side
by the way my my
my personal view is that
that you versus lamar odom in a boxing
match completely unfair i think like i
don't think there's any shame in losing
that fight
at least that went in there you went in
no it's like
it's like when johnny went in there with
butterbean you know what i mean right
obviously he knew he was gonna get
messed up but he was doing it to be like
yo it
the bigger the challenge you know let's
go for it sure of course
if i could have been a part of the
jackass i would have i would be i would
have made a great member of that show
with you guys you know what i mean like
no shame there's no shame in losing a
bite to
and he didn't knock me out he only just
gave me two concussions okay only two i
think that um
that
i i'm appalled that you only made
fifteen thousand dollars on that i only
made he only gave me 15 grand was it uh
it was a pay-per-view event right
yep
and he said he said the paper he said
the pay-per-view made no money
oh so you're supposed to get a piece of
the back end but he just said
but nothing i don't think that sounds
right because uh they were hyping it up
on tmz and [ __ ] like it's coming up like
there's no way that that didn't do some
pay-per-view well that's where i have to
say let go let god
and
and um
and just say
i don't want to waste my time with
auditing him i don't want to waste my
time with hiring attorneys clearly i was
[ __ ] over by the man in celebrity
boxing
and i will no longer do business with
them and that's it it's not personal
it's business but now it became personal
so you can you know
i did i did so much work i took out of
that 15 grand that i made i put 8 grand
into training
and then he got me a couple of
interviews so maybe like 30 grand total
with everything but i put like so
but that's like
you know 22 000 that's nothing he paid
lamar owed him 40 000
i found out
i mean even well perhaps celebrity
boxing since then has become like such
like all these youtubers boxing this is
reason as hell when was that when did
you find it this was just last year yeah
all right this year no no it was june
this is like a few months ago
yeah didn't realize that this is june
9th wow six days after a few days after
my sister passed away's birthday in june
so i
i was appalled that you know it's like
don't play me like that you know
like because
i'm gonna talk about it i'm gonna i'm
gonna find a platform and i'm gonna find
somebody you know that's gonna
because i'm controversial i say it
the way it is i'm not you know what i
have a saying
i'm never going to be a prisoner to
anybody's perception of me
good yeah it's the way to be you get it
right
sure you know yeah that's like because
then if you are you have no identity
you're constantly trying to be
what everyone else wants you to be
you're just trying to prove
and all that and that's just
that's just too much energy and too much
time spent
yeah well it's kind of like what steve
was saying like just ignoring those
comments and just kidding
yeah you know i've gotten to that point
where
i've
i kind of look over it but it's
entertaining for me too because listen
everybody says ignore ignore going
but we're not making a difference guys
if we're ignoring them if you're holding
people accountable and making them go on
facetime live and showing their face and
being like ah for me i don't know you
kind of give them what they want they go
to school the next day they're like dude
he put me on his live like it was crazy
i don't put on my i embarrass them and i
humiliate them right and i give them
what
about me and i saw it and i was like
dude that kind of hurt my feelings and
he was like oh my god i'm so sorry i
didn't even think you're gonna read it
like no that doesn't you know it's like
but i feel like trolls and people need
to be held accountable because you can't
yeah you get like
here's a saying for you silence is the
deadliest weapon yeah
yeah you're right no you're right you're
right but by acknowledging negativity
it's like you know pouring water to grow
it and feed it and nurture it right but
i still feel like i guess
water to grow
i respect your your your uh your opinion
about that but at the same time
i see some negative [ __ ] it's block and
delete pal
i don't know what they call it washing
their mouth out
for me for some reason it's it's it's
it's much more heightened than other
people
yeah it really is i i can't tell you
like look at the youtube videos guys i
mean come on
yeah i'm sure the hatred
that's true it's worse no it's it's it's
much it's much worse because i have all
the backstreet boy fans against me
because of what happened with nick
that's true oh man that's gnarly here
i'm gonna lower this mic a little bit
and uh
he's got a good joke
lux had some bangers
bangers the other day i forgot him
already what do you call a lesbian
dinosaur
a licolata puss
[Laughter]
you look bad
why did the monkey fall out of the tree
just dead
because nick shot it
hey i have a i have a quick question
[Applause]
i got i got a question for you so um
your son comes up to you when he's like
five or six years old yeah he's like
daddy
i love you
i want to get in the music
do you say not a chance in hell or of
course
i say um
emily's not going to say i want to get
into music what is what's going to
happen is that he's going to be raised
not around technology he's going to be
raised around pianos music his daddy
producing
with his grandma my mom picking
blueberries at the wiki wachu river in
florida uh we'll be in colorado by that
time you know and he's going to
be raised kind of like i was raised in
the grunge days in the 90s and stuff you
know why was the
uh strawberry so sad
because his mom and dad were in a jam
i have some but i cannot say them
wait so about it
where's popcorn
[Music]
what's moby dick's dad's name
i feel so alien i feel so alienated
right now i feel like i needed these
jokes in the last three years yeah like
all that [ __ ]
i feel bad about any of these jokes in
years oh my god that's so great
but wait oh sorry back to scott's
question what
what what if your kid comes to you when
he's like 10. and he's not saying i want
to be a musician he's saying dad i want
to be famous
like how do i wait can i be friends way
in hell i'm saying no way in hell yeah
same as the reality
it's not fame
it's not what it is it's not money it's
not fame you gotta remember i started at
seven years old in 1995
and i didn't have a wallet until i was
16 years old i didn't do it for money i
did it because i wanted to do cartwheels
climb up palm trees i can climb up a
straight telephone pole um
i'm down to see that i'll show you i'll
come i'll climb straight at that pool
right on like a monkey no seriously
better than anyone you've ever seen
watch me i'll show you guys after like
that but
no
but yeah so that's where the line would
be like if you want to get music you're
like that's dope make music but if he
was like i want to be famous i want to
be a celebrity he probably will want to
because he'll see like me and i'm not
gonna stop i'm a solo artist and i'm
gonna continue to evolve and that's kind
of where i'm going now with my my music
it's more of like a sting peter gabriel
type of vibe um so like a hybrid of that
cool and um you know just
uh real stories
real things relative in my life but if
he comes up to me and says i want to be
famous i'm going to say no
do you what's fame mean this is what i'm
going to ask him what's what's famous
mean
and i want to hear his answer
hooking up with a lot of chicks and then
making money but but he's not going to
be raised that way he's not going to be
on an ipad he's not going to have baby
shark drilled into his head for two
years
that's good
um you know
i i'm appalled by that with that baby
shark the the the parents that like
literally turn it on what's the baby
shark baby shark doo doo doo doo doo doo
yeah so
parents literally play to shut their
kids up all kinds of different things
and i'm appalled by it it's so funny
when parents are like oh all the kids
shows like i hate the kids shows but the
kids love them like if you never show
them that
they'll never
want it you know like
show them like seinfeld or whatever you
want to watch and they'll be like oh
this is what tv is i think i think i
think mike is going to be hopefully into
all like the marvel stuff because i'm a
huge fan of marvel and swords not like
paw patrol yeah i would just just never
robert downey jr because him and i both
went to mccollum hall at betty ford
center oh cool yeah nice yeah he's a
huge super guy you gotta get any touring
and stuff like uh
coming up yeah we're working on the
touring right now right now it's
important and imperative for me to be
there for the first couple years you
know for my son's life so i'll start up
i'll start up again maybe in
here you know i'm releasing the project
so and then i'm releasing the album on
my mom's birthday march 9th
so
you know to commemorate thank thank her
for
giving up her dreams
to
give me and nick hours and that's
something that another reason why i have
a problem with my brother is because he
he doesn't give her like even though she
suffers from alcoholism
i put her in rehab
two years ago yeah and uh took her to
the doctors who helped me and then
that's when i came out for the first
time about
actually being i said on the doctors i
lied to all the world and i want to tell
the truth i went to rehab for huffing
dust or kids
good man
um
so uh we got the the touring's just kind
of on the back burner yeah it is we're
working on i'm doing like one-off shows
working on the book uh you know i'll
wait i you know i i'm a very patient
person so i wait for the right energy to
approach me i'm no i'm in no rush you
know so
uh
i'm definitely going to take your advice
now by the way so i'll give you a shout
out on the back of the book
yeah no no for real because i think
that's a brilliant idea is to have the
editor you know work out the book first
and then write it out yeah just don't
write it down no handwriting until
you've got a dope no no no that's that's
brilliant but but it's also brilliant to
come up with a book like that because
then it makes it more art
it makes more of an art piece because
you guys have to see the person's
writing like a declaration of
independence right or and you can like
doodle in the sides or whatever it'll be
like
or there could be hidden little uh in
you like little cryptic messages in
there right little things the
declaration of iron carter so what other
stuff we got the clothing line that is
that out and available oh yeah the
clothing line is on erin carter.com i
actually
i also have a clothing line called baby
love which is for babies okay jumpers
calm yeah that's right aaron carter.com
too what other stuff are we promoting um
you know i have only fans too wow and i
do about i do about 50 or 60k a month
50 or 60k
what do you do on there
uh i do a little bit of everything i am
i'm the way i'm talking to you is no
different than how it would be on an
x-rated site so so you show your deck on
there oh yeah flip it around
you got a pretty big dig yeah it's
pretty big
nice dude you know i guess only fans is
a big revenue stream
i cleared 535 000 last year from oaf
yeah so i um yeah i have only fans and
uh it does great and it's crazy because
my fiance camera just overheated okay we
got that one yeah so basically my fiance
was on only fans
when i met her and i said and she i said
you know i'll i'll do only fans instead
and she's like well if you can make five
thousand dollars in a month then i'll
quit
i made seventy thousand dollars in three
days
nice and then i was like well
guess you got to get off of it and and
you know it's
you know so i have that i have the
clothing line you know i have uh i'm
into classic cars so uh
we saw a lot of cars in the driveway i
have my uh i have my uh my duster on the
way right now my plymouth duster on the
way i have a
also a 69 rs ss camaro with the aluminum
small block in it on the way so and then
a cadillac i got a
assembly
on instagram
i do lives all the time almost like a
reality show for people okay i make it
very like involved and i involved and
and i think that's where a lot of the
extra extra extra haters come from and
you know i don't give as much attention
as ice to them as
it seems like i'm saying
but
it pisses me off bro like like really
because then i think to myself
what if there's somebody that is a
professional
and a producer or something that's
watching this and they see this stuff
then
are they gonna believe it
yeah i don't know man exactly we don't
know we never know we never know if if
you get uh if you get a comment from a
smear campaign person that says
oh
he's a pedophile or something right
which is like one of the number one
things they like to do to people to ruin
them claim that they're a part of oh
he's a pedophile and then you get and
then someone sees like 200 likes on that
post
right well automatically they're going
to believe it but then if you go if you
click on the likes you'll see that their
bot accounts counts
mice and you know zero posts no
followers
all they follow is me
right one followers it's just me they
pay attention to my every move and it's
scary
is is there anything else that uh that
we want to plug
you know um
just of course the song honestly i would
love to i i obviously everyone knows but
you know i i just want to plug that um
it's an honor being here with you um i
appreciate that and i'm very excited for
jackass for dude i'm gonna i'm gonna
follow you again on twitter you know i
wish i could
yeah i will too
yeah and i aig yeah and we'll swap
numbers uh but you know i would i would
love to um
you know
if there's ever anything going on and
you guys are doing some goofy stuff yeah
we're going to come back and film with
you dude
i'm a daredevil i love doing this stuff
aaron carter it's just like that
a-a-r-o-n carter on ig i just hit the
follow on there there you go
and i'm gonna do the same on twitter all
right dude we'll [ __ ] say what's up
to dr drew for me yeah well
yeah
i know he uh helped you out a lot right
yeah big time i love dr drew and uh and
yeah let's get together and do some
tattoos that aren't on your face yeah
and if you guys ever got like if you
ever do a jackass five
please bring me in i would i would love
to be that's not my call but uh that's
okay
i'll bring some i'll bring some good
ratings don't worry for sure oh yeah
thanks dude this was awesome
yeah dude
what did you think of aaron carter
dude he's the most likable guest i think
we've had and i kind of want to hang out
with him
um
he's definitely friendly he's he's easy
to get along with
he uh
i think he's also polarizing but what
i'm really glad about is that
unlike a lot of interviews that we heard
about that we saw where people just like
went after him like we didn't real you
know we we tried to keep him honest we
we we
we weren't dicks but we weren't [ __ ]
who said that paul said we weren't dicks
on the episode and we weren't [ __ ]
either
yeah for sure and so and i was like here
dude you know i don't want to like
burn up a lot of time you know but of
course we'll be in the chat i don't know
that that um episode i i thought that i
was a little bit all over the place i i
don't know if it was my best job as a
podcaster i'll be sensitive to that in
the live chat but not nearly as
sensitive as i am to the news that came
from the gorgeous paul briskey
well
uh come february i'm gonna be moving on
is that what you're telling that's what
you want me to say right
you're acting surprised yeah i'm
surprised that you make it sound so
finished and official
i i thought it was a possibility
okay uh come february there's a strong
possibility
that i'll be um moving on to a new
chapter of my life maybe moving to
tucson who knows but i love you guys
love stevo love the wild ride ac for
life
[Laughter]